So, in the 1950s and 60s, British psychologist by the name of John Bowlby
developed a theory called attachment. And this was based on two observations.
The first observation was made by the animal behaviorist Konrad Lorenz. And
Lorenz had seen in baby geese that whoever cared for them became their mother.
it's not all that weird until you realize that the mother could be a human,
didn't have to be a goose. And this is what he called imprinting. The second
observation was made by Sigmund Freud. And Freud had observed that when mothers
go away from babies that the baby becomes really distressed, really upset. And
this, he called separation anxiety. So, it was imprinting on the one hand and
separation anxiety on the other hand that led John Bowlby to develop a theory
for why attachment to the caregiver is. So important in early stages of human
development.